نعود مشاهدينا الى موضوع ترامب ولائحه
الاتهام الطويله التي فاقت بنودها
الثلاثين بندا طبعا واجهها الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب لكن غابت
عنها ما وصفت بالجريمه الثانيه صحيفه وولز
مفقودات في لائحه الاتهامات 34 هذه لكي
تكون التهم جنائيه يحتاج المدعي العام الى
جريمه من نوع اخر فاين هي هذه الجريمه
الاخرى براجيا يزعم ان ترامب زور مرارا
سجلات تجاريه من الدرجه الاولى واخفى
معلومات عن جمهور الناخبين خلال
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لعام 2016 فيما تهمل
ابرز كانت شراء صوت بل صمت ممثله اباحيه
بمئه وثلاثين الف دولار دفعها مايكل كوهان
مساعده ترامب السابق هنا ادعاء
بان ترامب انتهك قوانين تمويل الحملات
الانتخابيه اسقط طبعا باعتراف كوهان بما
قام به وبحسب عضو سابق في لجنه الانتخابات
الفيدراليه ان الاموال المدفوعه
لا تشكل نفقات حمله انتخابيه جميع هذه
التهم هي فرديه وتزوير السجلات التجاريه
يعد جنحه في نيويورك وليس جنايه فما هي
الجريمه الاخرى التي يزعم ان ترامب يحاول
التستر عليها